Hey everybody, it's LeBron here.
I've got a quick brain teaser for you.
What are the odds of making 10 free throws in a row?
Here's my good friend Sal with the answer.
That's a great question, LeBron, and I think the answer might surprise you.
So, I looked up your career free throw percentage
and you are right at around 75%,
which is a little bit higher than my free throw percentage.
And one way to interpret that: if we have a million LeBron Jameses,
and you can imagine any large number
of LeBron Jameses taking a free throw.
Let's say, this line represents all of the
LeBron Jameses that take that first free throw.
Let's call that free throw number 1.
We would expect, on average, that 75% of them would make that first free throw.
So, let me draw 75%. So this is about halfway, this would be 25.
This would get us to 75. So we would expect
75% of them would make that first free throw.
And then the other 25%, we would expect on average,
would miss that first free throw.
Now, what we care about are the ones that keep making the free throws.
We want ten in a row!
So, let's just focus on the 75% that made the first one.
Some of these 25% might make some free throws going forward.
But we don't care about them anymore.
They are kind of out of the game!
So, let's go to free throw number two.
What percentage of the Lebron Jameses
that made that first free throw,
what percentage would we expect to make the second one?
And we're going to assume, whether or not you made the first one,
has no bearing on the probability of you making the second,
that this continues to be the probability
of a Lebron James making a given free throw.
So we would expect 75% of these Lebron Jameses to also make the second one.
We are going to take 75% of 75%.
So this is about half of that 75%; this would be a quarter,
this would be three fourths, which is exactly 75%, right over here.
So this represents: of the ones that made the first one,
how many also made the second one?
So you could say that the percentage of the Lebron Jameses
that we would expect on average
to make the first two free throws.
This length right over here is 75% of 75%.
75% of this 75% right over there.
And I think you might began to see a pattern emerging.
Let's go to the 3rd free throw: free throw number 3.
So what percentage of these folks are going to
make the third one?
Well, 75% of them are going to make the 3rd one!
What is this going to be?
This is going to be
75% of this number,
of this length, which is 75% of 75%.
And if you were to go all the way to free throw #10,
and I think you see the pattern here,
if we were to go all the way to free throw #10, so I am just skipping a bunch,
we are going to get some very, very, very small fraction
that have made all ten.
It's essentially going to be 75% x 75% x 75% 10 times.
75% being multiplied repeatedly 10 times.
So this is going to be what we're left off with,
this is going to be 75% x 75%
And let me copy and paste this, so it doesn't take forever...
I will put the multiplication signs on later.
So that's four, that's six, that's eight,
and then that is ten, right over there.
Let me throw the multiplication signs in there.
So this little fraction that made all ten of them
is going to be equaled to this value right over here.
75% of, let's see, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
75% being repeatedly multiplied 10 times.
Now, this would obviously take me forever to do by hand.
And even on a calculator,
if I were to punch all of this in,
I might make a mistake.
But lucky for us: there is a mathematical operator
that is essentially repeated multiplication.
And that's taking an exponent.
So another way of writing that,
we could write that as:
75% to the tenth power.
Repeatedly multiplying 75% ten times.
These are the same expression.
And 75%, the word "per-cent"
literally means "per hundred."
You might recognize the root word, "cent,"
from things like "century,"
100 years in a century, 100 cents in a dollar.
So this literally means "per hundred."
So we could write this as: 75 over 100 to the 10th power.
Which is the same thing as 0.75 to the tenth power.
Now let's get our calculator out
and see what this evaluates to.
So, 0.75 to the tenth power,
gets us to: 0.056.
And I'll just round to the nearest hundreds,
so if we'd round to the nearest hundreds,
that gets us to 0.06.
So this is roughly equal to (if we round to the nearest hundreds): 0.06
which is equal to, roughly when we round,
a 6% probability of
making ten free throws in a row!
Which even though you have quite a high free throw percentage,
this is not that high of a probability.
It's a little bit better than a one-in-twenty chance.
Now: what I want to throw out there for everyone else watching this,
is to think about how we can make a general statement about anybody,
if that anybody has some free throw percentage,
and they want to say: what's the probability of
making 10 in a row?
How can we say that?
Well, I think we saw the pattern right over here.
The probability of making, let's call it "n,"
where "n" is the number of free throws we care about,
n free throws in a row.
For somebody, and we are not just talking about LeBron here,
it's going to be their free throw percentage,
and this case, Lebron's was 75%,
to the number of free throws we want to get in a row.
So to the, nth power.
For example: you might want to play around
with your own free throw percentage.
If your free throw percentage is, let's say,
60%, which is the same thing as 0.6.
So let's say you have a 60% free throw percentage,
and you want to see your probability of
getting five in a row,
you would take that to the fifth power.
And you'd get, what looks like,
if you round it to the nearest hundreds,
would be about 8%.
So I encourage you to try this
with different free throw percentages,
and different numbers of free throws
that you are attempting to get in a row.